you may know him from such animated
series as Ray rendering and race shading
but
he has done let me show his improv
improv comedy
in front of Tony Hill
the Emmy award-winning actor from Veep
and Arrested Development so I'm sure
that wasn't stressful at all
so everyone please welcome Tyler
hi everyone my name is Tyler Morgan wall
I'm a research staff member at The
Institute for defense analyzes in
Alexandria Virginia and I'm the
developer of race Shader Ray render and
the rayvers a collection of packages
that enables you to create beautiful 3D
data visualizations all in our
and today I'm going to be talking about
how or showing you how you can build a
3D digital replica of a city completely
in r in only a few lines of code
um so I'm also going to show you why you
should use R to make stunning 3D data
visualizations and how you can
interactively fly through these scenes
uh without leaving your rsession
and finally I'm going to show you how
you can use this ability to help tell
data-driven stories Within These cities
so first uh let me start off with an
example of a beautiful hyper realistic
3D city city rendered entirely on a
computer
so this of course is a Sim City 2000 uh
released by Maxis in 1993. this overhead
isometric city building game
um lets you design and build your own
Metropolis uh and as a kid I love
playing this game although not in the
intended way of managing tax rates and
building sewer and electrical grids
um being a child I just use cheat codes
uh to get unlimited funds and do what I
actually found fun which is uh building
and designing cool looking cities
um and what in my opinion made a city
cool looking well it was creating towns
and cities that interacted with the
natural terrain and fun and interesting
ways uh building a city bisected by
multiple rivers or on top of plateau or
within a mountain range or a volcano
Caldera
and that's because Humanity in the
environment are intrinsically linked and
SimCity provided kid me a very easy
canvas to play with those Concepts and
in general representing that
intersection of humanity and the
environment is one of the goals of
cartography maps of the language of how
Dirt water and nature relate to flesh
and blood
um and this was one of the goals I
wanted to bring to R when I started
developing ratiator
but I had a problem
many of rayshader's 3D maps looked like
the empty pre-generated SimCity terrain
devoid of life and civilization
and since one of my goals with rayshader
was to help scientists and journalists
tell stories about how our changing
environment affects the people within it
I realized I had to find a way to add
Humanity to ratiators maps
and the utility of this goal was made
especially clear to me in June 2020 when
Andrew botran of the Washington Post
asked me if Ray Shader could be used to
help visualize and tell a story about
how the Trump Administration then used
helicopters against protesters during
the black lives matter protests here in
DC
this was intrinsically a 3D data-driven
story they had GPS and altitude data and
wanted to visualize the path of the
helicopter as it wove through the
buildings of downtown DC but at the time
ratiator only supported uh 3D terrain
and basic data like points and lines not
enough to build a publication worthy
visualization of the downtown area so
they had to use other tools but as
someone who believes you should be able
to use uh make any data visualization in
R I knew this was something that I had
to fix
so I did
um and here's what you'll learn in this
talk
um uh how to build a city from raw data
in r in just a few lines of code but
I'll also show you how you can integrate
other data into that 3D City and I'll
show you how to create animations and
explore your data interactively
but before we dive into 3D cities I'll
introduce the 3D ecosystem provided by
the ravers and show how you don't need
any three fancy 3D modeling skills in
order to create a stunning 3D databiz
and since the most common feedback I get
when I give a talk on 3D data
visualization is wow I wish I could make
something like that but I don't work 3D
data I'm also going to make sure to show
you some examples of 3D data
visualizations made from a variety of
different data sets all in all that
hopefully inspire you to try something
on your own
now there are a few packages out there
for 3D data visualization but I'm going
to be talking about the reverse the pat
set of packages I developed that focuses
on making high quality 3D renders with
realistic lighting the main package I'll
be using in this process is Ray Shader a
patch that enables you to transform your
data into 3D models the other reverse
package I'll be using is Ray render that
allows you to make beautiful path traced
3D data visualizations like it's from
blender but entirely in r
and all the spatial data manipulation
I'll show in this talk has done been
done with the simple features package
which allows you to import and parse
almost any kind of data in r
and finally our spatial data in our and
finally I'll be using the elevator
package to programmatically fetch
elevation data for our 3D maps
so you need to walk before you can run
uh so before we can build an entire 3D
City let's cover the basics what exactly
goes into a 3D data visualization what
are the different things you need to
keep in mind when putting together a 3D
dataviz
first what kind of data can be used for
3D plots so all you need for a 3D
database are data with at least three
numeric components here we have European
flight path data from the crowdsourced
Open Sky Network and flat flight path
data has altitude uh longitude and
latitude data which intuitively map here
to X Y and Z and are plotted as 3D paths
here
so this is a fairly straightforward and
intuitive use of 3D but you can also you
choose to use 3D Aesthetics with 2D data
much like you might choose a line chart
over a bar chart purely for aesthetic
reasons you might choose a 3D chart over
its 2D counterpart because you can make
it more interesting and Visually
appealing this is a map of these
submarine fiber optic cable network and
there's no actual 3D data present just
latitude and longitude data the cables
rise out of the Earth where they start
and fall back in where they end
you could easily plot this as 2D paths
on a simple world map but I think the
floating cables subtle shadows and
rotating Globe really Elevate what is
otherwise a fairly simple data set into
something more tangible and relatable on
a human scale like the Earth is being
wrapped in yarn
so many 2D plots have direct 3D
equivalence but just turning points and
lines into spheres and cylinders can
lead to mixed results data floating in
the void can his heart can be hard to
interpret if you're just presented with
a static image as objects in the
foreground can block those in the
background like we see here in the
static 3D rendering of a morphine
molecule generated with the rain
molecule package
but you can solve this problem by
animating the 3D data the movement
disambiguates the foreground from the
background so that the reader can fully
interpret the 3D model
besides points and lines the other main
type of 3D data visualization is the 3D
mesh a continuous grid of data values
this is where the ray Shader package
comes in it takes 2D grids of raster
data and uh and creates 3D models by
transforming that flat Matrix data into
3D
this visualization of the underwater
volcano in Tonga that erupted earlier
this year was generated from a simple 2D
Matrix of the Symmetry data taken from a
sonar survey check out the code to see
how straightforward this is from R
Matrix to 3D model in just a few lines
up uh there it is in just a few lines
and this is true of almost all the
visualizations you'll see in this talk
the rendering code is usually only a
dozen or so lines of our code and most
of the work is in cleaning and prepping
the data which it always is
now if you're the type of person that
obsesses over the tiniest details of
your data visualization great news 3D
database brings an entirely new type of
detail to obsess about lighting if
you've ever talked with a photographer
you know that the secret to uh amazing
photographs isn't necessarily having the
best camera but rather ensuring you have
adequate and well-designed lighting and
the same is true of 3D rendering if you
only have a single light like we have
here in this 3D historical map the
visualization is a bit spooky like a
swinging light bulb in a haunted house
uh but if we look at this visualization
of the blooming California poppy fields
with multiple distant fill lights we see
the atmosphere has changed completely
much brighter and less Moody
even easier than all of that is using an
HDR image file for environment-based
lighting which we see here in this
visualization of Monterey Bay California
it lights the scene with a real world
image which results in natural realistic
lighting like the object was actually in
that environment
and finally if your data changes over
time you can also also introduce
animation to your database here I've
used a Microsoft Connect to capture my
movements and load them into R using the
r mocap package there is a package for
everything
by extracting the individual time slices
and rendering each frame separately I
was able to combine all the frames into
this animation using the AV package
so now that we know the basics about
what goes into a 3D data visualization
let's build our city
so what do we have to do to accomplish
this well first we need spatial data
then we need to load parse and filter
that data to only what we need for our
visualization then we need to turn that
data into a 3D model and render it in R
so it sounds like a lot but thanks to
the great spatial R ecosystem and the
easy 3d rendering capabilities of the
reverse the hardest part by far is just
finding all the data you need
so where do we get our data uh well
first thing we need is elevation data to
create our base 3D map and we can get
this programmatically using the elevator
package for bodies of water and Road
data DC's open data portal to download
polygon data uh you can download polygon
data to demarcate the bodies of water
and Road data to Overlay the street
Network and most importantly for our
case DC has geo-referenced 3D building
data
so not every city will have all of these
data sets available uh or make it easy
to find but thankfully for our case DC
has a nice web portal for accessing all
this information
so this is all the code that it takes to
load our packages and our spatial data
our downloaded data and thankfully SF
you can see here makes loading spatial
data a breeze once we load our data with
st read we then want to ensure all of
the data is transformed so we load it
here and then we transform it to the
coordinate system that is specified in
the buildings data so that's what that
CRS means it says coordinate reference
system and then we transform it to that
so everything's being measured from the
same point
um and so we do this for each one of the
objects for the roads and for the water
bodies
and now that we've loaded it all um we
just need to download the elevation data
for our base map and convert it to a
matrix to input to ratiator so we'll use
the latitude and longitude uh
coordinates for from that intersection
from The Washington Post so that's what
these are I just pulled these from
Google Maps
and then uh we will transform that point
to the coordinate reference system uh
that was specified in the buildings
object and then we'll expand it by 10
kilometers to make sure we're pulling in
all of DC which will then crop down to
just the buildings uh the the extent of
the buildings data set
and then finally we use a ratiator's
raster to Matrix function to convert
that raster objects to a raster object
to a basic R Matrix and then we're done
importing all of our data
so to turn this into a 3D map uh we'll
just run this short ratiator script uh
so this code creates our 3D terrain
model by building up layers so starting
with the basic elevation the color the
color mapping and height shade uh
followed by some Shadows to get some
nice uh shading on on the actual uh
elevation data itself
followed by our overlays for the water
and Roads and then we pass these all to
plot 3D and get this
so this is a 3D map of all of DC not
unlike we see the shape of the terrain
thanks to the underlying elevation data
and Hill shade but we can also see the
road networks and waterways thanks to
the overlays and now all we need to do
is add our buildings with a single call
to Ray shaders render multi-polygon Z
function which is the file format that
it comes in
wait a minute or two to generate the
model because there's a lot of buildings
in DC
and now you have your full 3D digital
Recreation of every Hill Street and
building in DC generated directly from
spatial data in only a few lines of code
so this scene has over 38 million
vertices rendered in real time in your
rsession and this map is pretty neat I
mean we can see a lot of detail here but
while buildings and terrain are cool um
it seems a little Barren and that's
because we're missing really one
important element of our environment
trees
and I'm happy to tell you that not only
does Ray Shader now support adding a 3D
trees the maps it actually you can add a
lot of them
um so this is every single tree in DC 10
million of them detected from 30
gigabytes of lidar data covering all 68
square miles of DC
rendered within our digital replica
um you might think this is just a fun
rendering showing off the cool feature
of ratiator to handle millions of trees
but you can actually start to see public
policy impacts in just a single render
by rendering all the foliage in the city
you can actually see how in northwest DC
uh over here we actually have fairly
substantially more uh tree coverage and
canopy coverage than in Northeast DC and
this has real uh
uh real impacts when it comes to health
and wellness lower canopy coverage is
associated with higher summer
temperatures and with combined with the
gradual warming effects of climate
change actually leads to more Health
heat related Health emergencies
so being able to visualize that
disparity on a tree by tree basis is I
think really really powerful
um so you might also notice that the 3D
rendering so far have been a little flat
what I've been showing of DC and that's
because we've been using the raw Shader
output which is just faster to render if
we want something a little nicer we can
call Ray shaders blender high quality
function
and get a beautiful path traced
visualization with realistic lighting
so using a high quality visualization
techniques like path tracing can really
enhance the impact of your database and
increase engagement and interest from
your readers plus it just looks really
awesome
uh so you can see the National Mall here
rendered with buildings and trees all
derived from data but in addition to
trees and buildings ratiator can also
now reference uh arbitrary georeference
3D models which allows you to answer
such pressing questions
as what if we replace the Washington
Monument with a movie accurate version
of Soren's Dark Tower from The Lord of
the Rings
so Sauron 2024
now I've only showed you rotating views
of our map so far
um and you might ask how difficult it
would be to set up some more complex
visualizations flying through 3D space
and how would you even do that
programmatically so unlike in 2D where
there's only one way to look at
visualization in 3D you have an infinite
number of camera angles orientations and
settings to choose from so it can be
intimidating especially if you've never
worked in 3D before
but I've made it a little less daunting
by including a fully interactive
real-time 3D Graphics device built into
Ray render and working out of the box
with no dependencies so if you can use
ratiator interactively you can use this
3D rearrender View
so here I've recorded a video of myself
flying through DC visiting various
landmarks parks and stadiums throughout
the city you can fly around your scene
with just your mouse and keyboard and
find the best angle and print out your
camera angle info for future use or you
can interactively save keyframes and
generate an animation smoothly flying
through your data visualization like a
helicopter flying through a city
that's foreshadowing
so now let's see if we can recreate that
Washington Post data visualization in
our using rayshader and Ray render
um so we already have our 3D City model
but we need to import the helicopter
flight path data so how much code do we
need to do that
um so we need four lines of code we load
the geojson flight data using the
geojson SF package which includes
latitude longitude and altitude data for
the helicopter over its flight we then
again transform the data to the
coordinate system of the buildings data
set uh like we did with the road and
Waterway data and then we extract a data
frame of X and Y coordinates using the
St coordinates function and then plot it
in our 3D map using ratio's render path
function which we can see plotted over
there
and we're all done loading the data
but to fully recreate The Washington
Post visualization
um there's two things we really need to
do first we need to edit out all of this
helicopter data just to include the only
the region of a point of Interest so it
goes well beyond and well before the
actual time period we're interested in
and we also need to gray out the pretty
the pretty 3D model we have so we just
have so we really emphasize just the
flight so we remove all the great work
we did making that look all nice
so after we do all that
oh so yeah this is the code that it
takes to extract here we see here up
here we're extracting the data
um it's just a couple lines and then
here we just you specify various Shades
of Gray for everything and that's how we
turn our map substantially more boring
um so this we end up with this
Recreation done entirely in our
all in all it took about 50 lines of
code to go from raw data to fully formed
3D City so you can compare it to the
original and see we did it get about 95
percent there all that's left for us to
do is maybe add some labels and some
arrows and do a little post processing
to bring it up to the full uh
publication worthy uh status
but being able to do all of this work in
R means that we have a tight link
between our data analysis and
visualization
um so streamlining your workflow and
improving reproducibility and having
access to the great 3D rendering
ecosystem R has to offer means you can
produce these stunning 3D visuals
without needing to learn any new
languages or software Suites
and finally after completing this
visualization I had an idea
you see this past summer at our studio
conference I gave a talk on making
roller coasters in our basically putting
viewers into the data uh visualization
as a passenger on a 3D Thrill Ride
so while this overhead view is cool
wouldn't it be even cooler to see the
view from the flight from the
helicopter's perspective itself
so simply by using the helicopter's
coordinates as the input to the camera
position in Ray render
I was able to recreate the view from the
helicopter just by swapping out that one
line of code
so not not only have we shown a new and
interesting perspective on this data but
we've also invented an entirely new type
of data visualization the Star Wars
Death Star Trench Run plot
but in all seriousness the our ecosystem
is one of the best out there when it
comes to spatial data and 3D data
visualization
if you work with data and perform
analyzes in an urban environment being
able to create a and visualize your
visualize your results in a high quality
3D digital replica can help aid
understanding by your readers by placing
your data in a familiar and recognizable
environment
and using the r spatial ecosystem means
it's easy to integrate multiple
disparate sources of data into one
combined visualization and do it all in
a reproducible way
to me it feels like a cheat code for
mapping
so go forth build a city and thank you
for listening